[Music]
this is not a normal year we've been
looking at each other on screen and
occasionally from a distance of six feet
or more
as you know Stamford is a special place
the beauty of the campus the ability to
learn from brilliant faculty the culture
of collaboration and optimism and most
of all the people during your time at
the GSB you've gone from being a set of
individuals to being a class that's held
together by bonds that even social
distancing cannot diminish the pandemic
has shown how much the world needs
leaders for society who make decisions
based on data and reason who act boldly
who demonstrate compassion and inspire
others you are those leaders we are
counting on you to bring your ideas or
experience in your passion to whatever
you do and wherever you got
[Music]
congratulations to the Stanford Graduate
School of Business class of 2020 I am so
proud of all of you what you have
accomplished is remarkable
you have put yourselves on a journey
towards making a big impact in the world
simply put you are the absolute best of
our future leaders now I know this is
not exactly the graduation you were
expected at the same time today's
adversity makes your class a truly
historic and for now congratulations on
your incredible achievement
and welcome to the GSB
[Music]